Doctor Oz is here at the desk.
Yes
(clapping)
I'm trying to find things here.
And with me as always is my little
endorphin booster and yours, Mr Ross Matthews.
(claps)
Hi everybody, I've been learning so much
this whole show doctor.
You're kind Ross, very kind.
Oh my god obsessed.
Ross and I have a little surprise for you doctor Oz,
in honor of our first segment and what you said about
stress and anxiety due to clutter
Please
Ready Ross?
Yeah
Three, two, one
we're cleaning this desk off.
All right lets get it in here as fast as we can.
Here take some of these things too.
Gimme gimme gimme, hand them down hand them down
we can do it.
This is perfect
This is more than I thought.
This hasn't been cleaned since we started the show
in September.
Now we're talking.
That feels good, there's legit dust on here.
(laughs)
All right how do we feel?
Lightened, and now we could do surgery on this table
it's perfect.
Hey.
Stay tuned for next week.
I was just gonna say, alright you guys ready to
get into some headlines?
Yep always
First lets start with coffee now so many people need it
to feel bright eyed and bushy tailed in the morning
but Well And Good reports that instead of pouring a hot cup
down your gullet first thing you should actually wait
90 minutes, doctor oz why did they say this?
They interviewed a good friend of mine, the sleep
doctor Michael Bruce.
And he had a very good argument he said "when you get up
in the morning the alarm went off, you just got out
of the shower you have all this cortisol all this
adrenaline flowing through your body.
Do you really need more coffee to get you to where
you need to be?
So he argues very convincingly you should delay your coffee
about an hour and half in the morning.
I don't know doc I wake up in a good mood I'm like
belle from beauty and the beast but if I don't have
coffee within the first twenty minutes I turn into the beast
So you're addicted.
How dare you.
(laughs)
So Ross here's the deal, if there's anything that you must
do and it makes you miserable if you don't then you're
addicted to it so test yourself.
But wouldn't you say out of all the addictions coffees
the best one to have?
Probably the best one but I personally don't think
addictions of any kind are worth having, so just
nudge yourself a little bit do the experiment Ross
you never know maybe you can go an hour you won't be so
miserable.
Nudge you.
(laughs)
I have to say I'm like this person better provide
like a crutches and a muzzle because I will bite someones
head off and I'm gonna need to like crawl that is rough
no caffeine for ninety minutes I don't know if I could it.
I'd be so proud of us if we could do quitting coffee
and then you want to do something even better for us
we could try eye yoga, sounds like quite a stretch
but before you roll your eyes Harper's Bazaar reports
this isn't some wacky wellness trend but it's a practice
as old as yoga itself and apparently can help de stress and
improve your focus, doctor Oz why is it important to
exercise your eyes?
You're staring at screens all day long, period.
All of us are especially these days so your eyes are
not designed for that your eyes are supposed be looking for
an animal there or prey over there look far look near
so we need to recreate that experience it's demanded.
And it actually stretches your eyes out.
You know when I'm at the mall I'm looking for sales
twenty percent off, forty percent off I understand that
well you guys wanna try it since we're here and we
all brought our peepers?
Yes
This is an actual eye yoga exercise so I'm the yogi
and you're my pupils.
He'll be here all week try the corned beef.
Thank you thank you, you're like my sidekick this
is fun, all right this is actually called upward
gaze look to your left peripheral as far as you can okay?
Now go to your right as far as you can, and then clock ward
in circles.
But what's the point doctor oz like what would it benefit
to do eye yoga.
Well for one thing we store a lot of tension in our eyes
a lot of the headaches we get are from shoulders stress eye
stress they all add up and so you might as well keep
everything limber its the same reason you exercise
your lower back right?
Limber it up you won't be living with back pain.
I think eye exercises aren't just like that but its also
accommodation exercises look far look near look far look
near and you should never stare at a screen for more than
twenty minutes look away for twenty feet and take a break
every twenty minutes if you can.
Twenty twenty twenty
Yes
We have twenty twenty twenty vision
(laughs)